so when you look at a pattern in your
life or something you know when we are
not happy in one area of our life it's
actually our guidance system is sending
a signal that says something's wrong
it's like stop take a look at this
what's going on so you recognize this
signal in many ways this part of the you
know the the work
the first thing is you notice what's
manifesting for example somebody who's
ignoring you or somebody who's cheating
on you it's not about them
if you turn it around and say what does
it mean
that is accepting or allowing to be
ignored that is accepting and or
allowing to be cheated on or something
or what is it in me that's feeling not
worthy of making a lot of money or what
have you so then you start to recognize
these patterns in you because it's a
dynamic it's like you know it's it's
it's it's a little bit more than the Law
of Attraction but even just that you
know by looking at the patterns tells
you what's in your subconscious mind
but there are other methods as well is
regardless of the person or the
circumstance you through a little bit of
meditation and a little bit of training
not not that much you start to feel you
intend
for the emotions associated with that
pattern to come up because the emotions
are part of your guidance system we
think like you know we shouldn't feel
angry or when we're angry we should like
pretend that we're happy or like say
affirmation I'm happy I'm happy or you
know but actually you're not you know
yeah right
so affirmations don't really work
because you're kind of forcing yourself
to say something but that's not how you
really really feel so I prefer to look
at the emotion if I really feel bad
what's that about I'm not gonna pretend
and say I'm I feel amazing when I really
deep inside me I feel bad so with this
exercise you can through breathing and
like I said intention you begin to feel
what you know where you are struggling
so it's very powerful exercise because
all kinds of stuff starts to come out
something that seems irrelevant and this
is where the past life and ancestral
thing comes in
so so all sorts of strange things start
to come up let's say you're unhappy at
work and all of a sudden you have
feelings of being abandoned and you're
like what like what what does this have
to do with that you are tapping into
subconscious experiences that happen to
you that trigger a feeling of being
abandoned which triggers the belief
system see when you as a child when you
feel abandoned not loved you come to a
conclusion oh my father left therefore
I'm not good enough I'm abandoned my
father left home because therefore I'm a
failure I didn't I wasn't lovable enough
for him to stick around does that make
sense yeah the feelings get you to
create belief systems right this book
and the second you have a belief system
a new belief system you didn't you
didn't come in you you weren't born
saying I want to be abandoned you you
were born saying give me love give me
food so I can Thrive that's what you
came to do so it was later when you're
three or four or five life
that through these external experiences
the feelings give you change your belief
systems yeah they're like they're like
they they they're like the start of a
new code exactly and that's the
beginning of the pattern
now at the age of five when your dad
left
you start you you are adding information
to yourselves to your cellular memory
you are saying yes I'm a young boy or
girl or whatever or this and that I have
many friends but also I'm not good
enough to keep to to keep my Father's
Love For example you add this
information to your cellular memory as a
side note I want to say that your
thoughts
aren't abstract I mean of course they're
abstract like you don't see them
but it's an actual charge it's an actual
vibrate like it's an actual frequency
that's generated from your brain think
about it like almost like a wave right
like it's the thought it still carries
information in the form of a waveform
exactly energy
and Einstein even said once uh energy
cannot be destroyed once created it can
be transmuted cannot be destroyed so
this is a form of energy this waves I'm
a failure I'm not good enough you know
is being produced right
where do you think these waves go
they go to other people and they latch
onto them like glue and they bring them
towards you
that but before they do that
they go into yourselves yeah and so
that's why when you do this exercise
you normally you would feel these
emotions in certain parts of your body
some people feel it in the heart some
people feel it in the livers people feel
it in their legs why
it's because this is where the weakness
after years and years and years from the
age of four I started telling myself
that I'm not good enough I'm a failure
you know for years and years then I'm
going to keep attracting
you know experiences that match my new
belief system so I'm gonna attract a
girlfriend or a boyfriend who's who's
gonna abandon me same patterns so on and
so forth
actually fast forward I'm going to
attract a job do you see what I mean you
see how like you don't think there's a
connection but there's a connection with
everything by the time I'm 30 40 what
have you I'm in a career right that I
hate
but I'm still there to pay the rent or
or what have you and I am miserable
you've abandon yourself too that's why
you're there because you abandon
yourself and what you really want so
your job is now information about you I
love that idea like you know you said
when something happens ask what the
question I ask is what's my part well
you always play A Part even if it isn't
your fault necessarily doesn't mean you
didn't attract that situation to show
you something
exactly there's you always have a part
that's the idea because you are the
Creator
we don't want to have a party you'll say
wait a minute I didn't attract my create
my cancer I didn't create this so this
is kind of where now we kind of to
continue how how do you undo this and
how do you get to the ancestral heart or
even past life yeah so so now here comes
a 30 year old person who's very unhappy
with work miserable every day has
developed a few illnesses or a few
struggle physical illnesses because the
liver that you've been pouring those
thoughts into I'm a failure I'm
abandoned I'm not good enough these
thoughts all went to your liver
so by the time you're 30 you have
problems with your liver or what have
you right
so you he comes to you and he says uh I
hate my job but I want I can't get out
because I have to pay a rent and I have
this physical problem if you know what I
mean it's all connected
so the idea with this type of training
is as you sit with the emotions
you're going to start to feel
like I said strange emotions that will
come up
and you will feel them in your liver
so as you look at the cellular memory
with this again if you're somebody's
training you're helping you but even you
you can do it with yourself
you if you feel these emotion mostly in
your liver
so you start to focus on the liver and
as if like you you visualize or you
imagine that you have like a zoom you
know like in a camera so you're looking
deeper and deeper let me feel let me
sense what is in my liver that's
triggering this problem and this huge
sense of Abandonment and sadness and
you're going to start to feel and see
things and if you are in this proper
alignment
you're probably going to see your dad
leave the home at the age of four so
that basically is the root cause
of your liver problem but also your job
situation and so on so forth you see
what I mean
sometimes it goes even before
you were even born
and this is where because you keep kind
of zooming in you keep going into the
cellular memory the cellular memory
stores everything of your body that's
why it's called memory and so if you
keep going deeper and deeper asking okay
but why did I even attract this father
to leave me at the age of four I came in
wanting lava yeah why this father why
this and that you keep going backwards
and this is where you get into another
life and another life and an ancestral
things and then you keep finding
the root cause of what's happening to
you in this lifetime and the second you
do it's no longer subconscious
you bring it up to the surface and it's
healed yeah
I've found that too when you like I've
done really really positive work with
EMDR
um and some somatic stuff on my own but
it's like
the the emotion is what you know marks
the beginning of a code or the beginning
beginning of any code a new code and
when there's a motion connected to it
whether it's like healing something from
a pattern or even manifesting something
even going into meditation and thinking
about something that I want
if I really go into the energy of what
it is how it would feel taste smell the
reasons why and just like be there in it
like
I'm now anchored in that reality having
happened it's just a matter of time for
this third dimensional reality to prove
it out and show me but it's already
happened and
um so I've I've had both of those things
totally work which is how I generated my
first trip to Egypt which is how I have
changed past memories it's all through
emotion yes exactly that's what I was
saying the emotions are your guidance
system yeah you know you can't you can't
ignore you can't say I mean you can but
it's a you know you can't say I'm happy
when you really are not go to where
you're not it doesn't mean you're gonna
stay there it just means that it's it's
just a guy it's just telling you start
there yeah
and then when you do this is kind of
where you go in and you undo it and then
you can move into the vision
so what you're saying is very
fascinating because what you just
explained and shared is means that
you're creating from the future you are
creating what you want from that place
in the future and that's the most
powerful way to create from the future
especially if you the feeling is so
powerful and it's the real feeling so
yeah meaning when you're there you're a
hundred percent feeling like every inch
of your body is I Cry Sometimes I laugh
I smile I get hot my heart rate gets up
like various different visceral
expressions of what I'm going through
if you like this clip
clip whole episode click at the bottom
of your screen